the universe is pretty big and very
strange hundreds of billions of galaxies
with sextillions of stars and planets
and in the middle of it all there's
Earth with you and us but as enormous as
the universe seems looking up it seems
to get even larger when you start
looking down
you are towering over worlds within
worlds within worlds each in plain sight
and yet hidden from your experience
let's go on a journey we'll start in a
park about a thousand meters long enough
for a 50-minute walk every time we click
this magic button we'll become a
thousand times smaller please slip into
this magic science suit so you don't die
and can still see
ready let's go
[Music]
the miniature Realm
you are the size of a grain of sand just
two millimeters High standing on a blade
of grass that seems as tall as an
eight-story building to you a square
meter of lawn is now a dense
metropolitan area with one hundred
thousand blades or two Manhattans worth
of grass Towers
from your new tiny perspective the park
that you could quickly stroll through
before is now the size of France
Crossing it would take at least a week
human-sized humans Loom over you four
times taller than the Empire State
Building their steps falling from
Horizon to Horizon
a bee the size of a helicopter lands
near you making the ground shake as its
hairy carapace vibrates with each Wing
beat you try to escape but are barely
able to move because the air is so gooey
before you click the button air
resistance was barely noticeable but as
you're now a thousand times smaller it's
as if the air has become a thousand
times denser it feels like you're moving
through honey
flying insects like bees use this to
their advantage their wings are not made
for gliding but like paddles that row
through the air
scaled up to human size the bee would
outrun a Concord Jet except it couldn't
even take off because it would be too
heavy for its wings
[Music]
the microscopic Realm you've entered the
microscopic realm and are now less than
two micrometers tall about the size of
an E coli bacteria
from your new tiny perspective the park
you started in is now a million
kilometers wide to you if you walked
non-stop it would take some 25 years to
cross it
it's hard to grasp just how huge the
microscopic world is to its tiny
inhabitants
the giant bee that was close a moment
ago is now the size of Mount Everest
towering High into the sky but alive
humming and vibrating
the air here feels almost solid to you
on the human scale it would be as
viscous as lava extremely hard to push
through
the blade of grass now expands so far
you can't see its edges stretching as
wide as Paris would to a regular sized
human you see valleys that look like
dried up riverbeds dead patches like
deserts and giant craters left behind by
voracious aphids but if you look closely
this is not terrain these are rows of
individual cells each the size of a
house with hard exteriors like glass
shells every few cells there are huge
openings called stomata like mouths
sucking in air and blowing out oxygen
suddenly the gigantic bee begins to move
a construct made of rigid pieces that
slide against each other like a suit of
armor it takes off to escape a drop of
water the size of an asteroid that fell
from another blade of grass and is now
rushing at you at breathtaking speeds
you brace for impact but instead of
feeling a strong punch you just get
sucked in you try to swim but the water
feels thick and sticky and holds onto
your limbs Like Glue
air molecules are free Spirits while
water molecules act more like social
creatures that group together whenever
possible they pull on each other and
create a relatively strong cohesive
force that traps you you can't help it
but you're still moving tumbling in all
directions helplessly dragged Along by
an invisible current floating in this
miniature Lake are tens of thousands of
microorganisms they take on many forms
viruses the size of tennis balls float
around you aimlessly others like euglena
oxyurac cells pass you like freight
trains
but most look like oily jellyfish the
size of a car sporting long tentacles
that act like supercharged propellers
despite the water holding onto them like
glue some move hundreds of body lengths
per second equivalent to a person
shoveling through mud at over 600
kilometers an hour
however bacteria weigh so little and
water is so viscous that they basically
have no inertia there is no gliding on
this scale
the result is a weird jerky motion
that's hard to keep track of maybe we
can learn more about this strange motion
if we go even deeper
the molecule realm you've become the
size of a molecule just under two
nanometers wide at your new tiny scale
the droplet now seems as big as the moon
to a regular human the blade of grass it
rests on could reach from the tip of
Alaska to the end of Australia and the
park is now almost the size of the solar
system but instead of mostly empty space
it is filled with stuff
everywhere you look there are
innumerable amounts of molecules and
atoms the rigid walls of the grass cells
beneath you are clearly vibrating
Rippling with waves of energy
the water droplet contains nearly a
sextillion water molecules that are all
in motion water is actually a storm of
H2O molecules smashing into each other
hundreds of trillions of times a second
each of them is moving at speeds of
around 2 300 kilometers an hour and
bombard their surroundings mercilessly
sending small objects hurtling in all
directions
this is the source of the invisible
current that you noticed when you were a
thousand times larger
scaling the speed up to the human scale
is impossible as a human-sized molecule
would be 2 000 times faster than the
speed of light
all this Furious motion comes from heat
heat is a bit abstract at our human
scale where you touch something and get
a vague sense of whether it's hot or
cold but down here you really feel what
heat is the motion of molecules
vibrating twisting and colliding as if
they're inside a furious ball pit
when these molecules lose heat they move
more slowly and Collide less often when
they gain heat they speed up and smash
together with renewed fervor temperature
is basically the measure of the average
speed of these fantastic dancers
performing all day
suddenly a molecule hits you especially
hard and you're catapulted out of the
water droplet into the air again and
here you see something unexpected
the stuff between the air molecules
nothing between the molecules that make
up the air there is a vacuum
on average a molecule in the air travels
for about 60 nanometers which is about
the length of a hockey rink if it were
the size of a human
if we were to compress all the molecules
and atoms buzzing around in the room
you're watching this in they would only
fill about 0.1 percent of its volume
99.9 of the space around you is a vacuum
you just don't notice it which also
means that every time you take a breath
you breathe in mostly nothing with a few
atoms
the subatomic Realm
at your size of under two picometers
scale starts to lose its meaning a human
would be nearly 2 billion kilometers
tall relative to you so large they could
stretch their arms from the Sun to
Saturn
an atomic nucleus would be the size of a
grain of sand you could hold on the tip
of your finger that grain holds 99.97 of
the atom's mass
the rest a sphere of influence about as
large as the Eiffel Tower from your
perspective is filled with an electron
cloud that's basically all the places
where electrons might be at any given
moment in time
electrons are shape shifters that morph
around outside the nucleus creating a
new and vibrating mess of different
shapes with every new moment
unlike the graceful motion of planets
the atomic nuclei are chaotic blurs
they bulge roll quiver and breathe they
hold back the same energy that powers
nuclear bombs and it doesn't let them
sit still they twist and vibrate six
tillions of times a second
it's time to end our journey and return
to
what you doing
stop it
the smallest place
we have reached the bottom the border
between reality and unreality
the scale here is the Planck length
which is the distance light travels in a
Planck time Planck time is the time it
takes light to travel a Planck length
hmm okay none of our models of the
universe make sense at Scales smaller
than this so for now this is it
we think that down here particles bubble
into existence and then spontaneously
disappear creating a quantum foam of
unimaginable energy can we go even
smaller we don't know
it's time to return
[Music]
[Music]
if you look up the universe is large and
strange so incredibly large and strange
but if you look down into the tiny and
extremely tiny the universe seems even
larger and even stranger in the end the
perfect place might be where you are
right now not too big not too small
foreign
these Hidden Worlds are all part of our
12023 shubin era Canada this time you
can join us on a journey through the
microcosm with each turn of the page you
will reveal a new world you didn't know
existed right beneath your feet
you know the drill by now as always it's
a super high quality calendar very shiny
and only available for a short time we
also have a few special deals for you in
our shop the calendar is a true piece of
quotes because Arts you can take home
with you and we say this every year but
it's true every calendar purchase
directly supports what we do here at
kodzkazat
and that's not just creating videos but
sparking curiosity all around the world
so because of you we can spread
knowledge and ignite an appreciation for
space nature and life in people
everywhere thank you so much for making
this possible
have a wonderful 12023.
see you down in January
[Music]
[Music]